Welcome in, welcome in, welcome in.
Welcome, welcome.
Hey you.
Hey you!
Welcome...
Sorry.
Welcome to... not the Henry Stickman.
Henry Stickmin.
Minto.
Henry Stickminto maybe.
I don't think I would be a Henry though.
Hi Minto.
Hi!
I'm looking extra...
What shape is that?
Thank you Henry Phantom for today's stream.
No!
I think I'd be more of like a Larry.
If I had to... If I had to give myself another name.
Larry?
What's wrong with Larry?
Anyway, welcome everybody.
So, welcome to membership.
I'm Wolf Inokichi.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you guys.
Larry Phantom.
Lawrence?
Lawrence.
That's like... That's like such a...
That's like the birth certificate name.
The death certificate name rather.
Hello Minto.
Hello!
Delta!
Thank you for the 5 gifted and Takizo!
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you guys.
You can see the resemblance between me and Henry Stickmin.
Is it because...
I got big ol' eyeballs?
And...
What other...
Other similarities?
I don't quite see it.
Pinky in the brain and Larry.
Maybe that's where my Larryness comes from.
Maybe that's why I want to be Larry.
I love that episode, Pinky in the brain.
And I love that it's all petty.
It's all just built... It was all created out of pettiness.
You just can't see his hair due to how the projection works.
He's not bald.
I believe you.
Logan, thanks for the 5 gifted and PacType.
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
And Drango, thanks for the 20 gifted.
My goodness.
Hi Minto.
I didn't want to interrupt the collab yesterday, but it was my birthday.
I was wondering if I could get a song from my kami...
Oh, I see.
Thank you for everything.
Always record for us, Wisps.
I just wanted to say that.
I really appreciate it.
Space is ghost!
OK, we sing happy birthday and then we can start.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Space is ghost.
That's me.
Well not Space is ghost, but a ghost.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday!
Sorry I missed you yesterday.
Pekka says thanks for the 10 gifted.
Why is everybody gifting so many?
Thank you!
I'm a ghost.
Not a space ghost.
I'm a maid ghost.
Just a maid ghost.
Anyway, let's play the Henry Stickmin Collection.
I have played this game only once ever before in my afterlife.
But it was many years ago, so I don't really remember much about anything.
So, I'll probably make mistakes.
And I might sometimes not choose the choice that you want me to choose.
Just try not to get too excited and try not to yell at me too much in chat.
I'm sensitive.
So, try not to scream at me in the chat to tell me what to do.
Because it will make me not want to do it even more.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the 5 gifted.
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Detroit, thank you for the pink.
Yato, thank you for the 5.
Fubidu, thank you for the 5.
And Ducky, thank you for the 5 gifted.
Thank you guys all so much.
We died.
I just finished planning for my Japan trip happening in 2 weeks.
I'll be sure to visit Cafe-san for the collab.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
So, remember to pick everything to see.
Pick everything?
I won't be here for too long.
Can we tell you after the game finish?
What do you want to tell me?
What are you trying to tell me, Aiden?
Invisible Moose, thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you so much.
Multiple streams.
Everything.
Can't spoil.
It has many wrong choices, but it does not have incorrect choices.
That's so true.
Doesn't the game encourage you to fail a bunch anyway?
It encourages you to see all the silly nonsense going on.
Thank you for the Akazupa.
Finally using this for a special occasion as I was always a VOD watcher.
It's my birthday.
I hope you have a beautiful day with Henry.
Scream at her guys, make the VOD more fun.
No!
Don't scream!
Oh my gosh, 2 birthdays!
Zankou, awesome!
Oh my goodness.
I have 2.
We have more birthday songs to sing.
And then...
And then we can start the game.
Or is it Slyve?
Slyve?
Have I been saying it?
Wait.
Slyve.
WiFi time!
Happy birthday!
Um...
Yeah.
It's perfect for all those girl fails out in the world.
Couldn't be me.
Start over.
Why is the game so loud?
Wait, I think there is subtitles.
We need to reserve a spot for the collab cafe.
Um...
I don't know.
I do not know.
What is a B2B?
Oh, breaking the bank.
It's only the prologue.
We're fine.
Oh yeah.
Shovel, explosives...
Oh my gosh, there is so many.
Um, obviously...
The disguise would always work best.
I, you know...
It's one of those like...
It's one of those...
Wait, did I get it first try?
That makes sense.
No way!
I was like...
I was gonna say it's kind of a manifestation thing.
You want to become...
Nevermind.
Why Henry?
Henry!
Wait, did I make it in?
Wait.
Oh, there was a...
What's a achoo?
Oh, achievements!
And bios.
Oh, okay, okay.
Of the characters.
Of course I love that guy who was...
Standing out there.
Remember the guy who asked about the bank?
He's like the most...
Okay, wait.
You have to click the characters to unlock them.
Let's try again then.
Retry, retry.
Wait a second though.
Okay, hold on.
We already know what the true one is.
It's real Metal Gear fashion.
I think...
If I were to say...
Let's say if I knew that this...
Or if I didn't know that this was...
I mean that's such an obvious choice, isn't it?
Where does the teleporter send us to?
Oh!
Oh no.
We're not...oh fail.
Cement.
Flame.
Yeah, I'm just too good at this game.
I'm so sorry.
Is there a car?
Explosions?
I like those too.
Oh no.
Gosh, Henry...
He's the real girl fail, I think.
Maybe.
I think he's the real girl fail.
Here, shovel.
This is also a classic.
This is like a classic Looney Tunes style.
Oh my gosh, where are we going?
Oh no!
What?
Oh my gosh.
Why would there be...
The cars have...
Can't have that going off all day.
Wait, I got an achievement for that.
I was just trying to see if the cars had bios.
Ok now, I guess we're doing all of them.
Laser!
But I probably won't do this for all of them.
Unless I get it first try.
Nice.
Oh.
Not nice.
Wrecking ball.
Miley Cyrus style.
I'm clicking on him.
Oh he's like what?
We didn't schedule for today?
What?
There is no construction scheduled for today.
Literally.
Oh it's right click.
You gotta right click.
Ok, hold on.
I probably will be able to get them with this one.
Ok, we continue.
Right, right.
This guy...
Sounds like grandpa.
Yes!
Who is he?
They're gonna kill him for questioning too much.
It includes Henry, but I got the achievement so...
No, I'm clicking on him.
It doesn't do anything.
But we made it inside.
We're such a bad boy.
Oh my god.
We're not robbing the bank.
We're just... Why didn't we go through the front door?
Escaping the prison.
Aw yeah.
Nice cursor, thank you.
Oh yeah.
Where...
Oh.
Yeah, yeah.
Of course I checked it.
I mean, if I didn't check it, I'd lose my job.
And I don't wanna lose my job.
Oh Dave.
See you around.
Happy birthday to us.
Another classic.
A file.
Right?
What is a NRG drink?
NR...
NRG drink.
Energy.
NRG.
Like a Gatorade?
Oh gosh, the drill one is so loud.
I'm gonna... You know what?
I'm letting the teleporter redeem itself.
Oh yeah.
You just can't seem to get the hang of that thing, can you?
It's like literally the safest place to ever do it.
Oops.
Retry.
We're fine.
You know what?
Let's try the NRG drink.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
What's in this thing?
Who are you?
That's Larry right there.
Oh my gosh.
Dave.
Oh my god!
Throw him out.
Who are you?
I can barely see your name.
Was it so easy?
Oh no.
NRG side effects include nausea, headaches, rapid heart rate and possibilities of stroke and or heart attack.
Henry Stickmin lord goes crazy.
Who have we seen?
Oh my gosh.
There are still so many guys.
We got Dave Pampa.
Rupert Price.
What are these names?
We got Blade Knife Man McGee.
Who is this guy?
Kev Portley.
He wants to eat donuts.
He just wants to eat donuts.
Stump Blump.
Ryan Goldman.
Oh that's what it said.
Employee of the month.
Fancy.
Oh they have different rarities too.
Or Dragon Balls?
What are these?
This is a 3 Dragon Ball.
I kind of like Knife Man.
Evil Knife Guy.
Cool.
Nice.
Here is Stump Blump.
Oh gosh.
If I were in this situation...
See a drill just makes too much sense.
What if I call...
With a cellphone you can do anything.
Ever.
You can...as long as you have service.
Oh my gosh an attorney!
Why are we Ace Attorney?
Wait, actual Ace Attorney!
Hm?
OBJECTION!
How did I know?
Who the hell is you?
Wait.
I forgot to get the BIOS.
What is this?
Defendant suffered many bruises and cuts.
Security footage of the night of the intrusion shows the defendant leaving his disguise and setting off the alarm.
Device...Diagram...Wait what was it?
I wasn't paying attention.
Our attorney's badge!
Ok, I'm not going to lie.
The badge looks so delicious in Ace Attorney.
It looks like a little cookie.
When I was a kid I always wanted to eat it.
Present the badge.
Oh I already had it.
That's right.
What is this?
It's evidence.
And how exactly does this prove anything?
Why?
I was just kidding.
This is no time for jokes.
I see no reason to further prolong this trial.
I find the defendant Henry Stickmin.
I could have gotten out of that, couldn't I?
Wait!
Oh!
We're here, we're here.
I'm trying to find evidence of something.
Oh wait, the knot is tied on the outside.
Wait, maybe that.
How could I do that?
Is that the bag the defendant hid in?
Yes, but there's one thing that's been bothering me.
How did he tie it?
If the defendant really was hiding in this bag then...
How did he tie the knot from the outside of the bag?
If he was inside the bag, it would be impossible for him to tie that knot on the outside.
But then, how did he do it?
It's simple.
He didn't.
What are you saying?
Who is this guy?
The defendant wasn't hiding in that bag at all.
He was stopped in there by this very witness.
As you can see by this doctor's analysis, the defendant had taken quite the beating.
While he was in the bag, he was unconscious.
Oh my god, this is some real gaslighting.
This is absurd.
This is some grade A gaslighting here.
It's Von Karma.
What?
All the other body bags?
You guys can't...this can't be happening to me!
Ah, classic crash out.
Classic Ace Attorney crash out.
I'm getting busted for some...
Oh yeah!
Not guilty!
Yay!
Confetti!
I'm wired up!
Did I win?
It's so loud all of a sudden.
I did so well, actually.
I missed so many people.
We need to know who this guy is.
Wait.
We learned these guys.
Felix White.
Hubert Brown.
Is everybody a color?
Vladimir Von Braun.
Winston Davis.
Stupid Winston.
Who the hell is this guy?
Skelly!
Oh no, ok.
It doesn't let me re-go back.
So I guess we'll just continue onward.
I don't...what's the map?
Oh wait, can I skip to here?
Oh, well, I just skipped.
Just kidding.
Ok, this one is definitely gonna get us to Skellyman.
I gotta know.
Who is he?
We made it to the...oh, to a bathroom.
Oh!
What's a...
Oppositator.
Opacity.
Oh, you'll walk through walls.
Just move the blue slider to the right and you'll become opaque.
Oh!
The more opaque you get, the easier it will be for you to pass through solid objects.
But what if I cut through the world?
Ok.
What if I...have I become too opaque?
See?
Here I go.
I got him.
There is a knife.
There he is!
Oopsie.
Wait, so crowbar...
We do this and then we are sneaking through the sewer.
Hello?
That guy has got kind of a giant gun.
Wait, is there more than one way to get out of here?
Left!
Wait, what happened?
Try dodging the bullets, noob!
Multiple endings?
No way!
I said three endings.
I didn't know if those were fails or not.
I don't know.
Such a product of it's time.
Oh, this way!
Sorry.
I'm good.
I know.
They just have too big of guns!
Left!
Lowbrow reference?
Huh?
What?
Like, obviously smash, but...
You can slip and brawl.
No way.
Wait, did I not press this button before?
Maybe I'm...
Get Matrixed!
Oh, I already got him.
Get ready.
I'm ready.
Ready?
Oh, nevermind.
That seems a little unfair.
Skip, skip, skip.
I said click.
Ok, I'm going to click as fast as I can.
Not ready.
I was ready!
Oh yeah!
Oh my God!
Yeah, skinny Willy.
Right there.
Oh my God!
Bang!
Don't turn your back on them, Henry!
I think this was my favorite one.
As much as I love Ace Attorney...
BBO...
What does that mean?
Oh, wait.
Badass...
Audi.
Ok, so we did that one.
Now we... Wait, 2 out of 4?
We did the teleporter.
We did the cellphone, we did the joke, we did the energy drink.
Ok, now we just have...
The file.
The window!
Oh my gosh, a classic.
I should have known that.
We have literally seen that.
We are on like the 10th floor.
The door, the door.
How was I supposed to know he wouldn't grow like little spiders on his fingers and crawl down the walls?
What was he?
I clicked!
Click!
Yeah!
I was also trying to get bios though.
He's escaping.
No, I'm not.
Ok, so belt and grenades just sound cooler, right?
Oh my god!
No!
Oopsie.
In theory that would have been better.
Our throw was just too good.
Too precise.
Left or right guys?
Left or right?
Gamers...
It's like when you follow the path of a wall, right?
Left!
And a maze, right?
Hi!
So rude to the janitor.
Get a lady.
What do you mean fatty?
No!
I think I missed one though.
Hold on, I'm going to try and go back there.
I'm going to try and go back and get that one bio.
I'm not trying 100% the game or anything, but I don't know how I'm feeling.
I'm going 100% right now.
It's this guy.
I got the other guy.
We got him!
You sure?
I'm just looking around.
You guys know I like to explore.
Just a box.
In that box are plungers!
These are the best ones.
Yeah, just like that!
Worry fatty Minto.
No!
Sneaky escapist.
I'm too good.
There are just a few fails that we haven't gotten.
Let's see, if I go back here.
And we do the rocket launcher.
We were...
Again, our aim is just too precise.
Our aim is too good.
1 out of 2?
Oh!
Wait, 0 out of 3?
I see, I see.
So we click here, but we don't click on the other one.
What?
He sounded so wimpy.
Ok, now here...
You guys, I'm just so good at being sneaky and everything.
I knew the plungers would work immediately.
It's the obvious, obvious, the most obvious choice.
Dave isn't a wimp.
How many people...
Look at this.
Who are these guys?
Who?
There's all like just tiny people.
Who are you?
There's so many people.
Look, I almost got every single person here.
Carlos.
Harold.
Straight shoot.
My gosh.
These are the...
No, these aren't the...
These are not the Matrix guys.
Oh, maybe these are the Matrix guys.
Yeah, yeah, these ones at the bottom.
John?
Who is the lady with the long hair?
We got... Oh, Jen.
Wasn't there another person with the last name Brun?
Conflict of interest?
A Nepo baby?
Ok, anyway.
Let's do the rope.
What?
Where did it even connect to?
Is there a chute?
Isekai.
BB Kim's actual Henry Stickman.
Oh!
I think it was just a regular backpack.
See what happens when you assume.
That's so dumb.
Ok, jetpack.
That's the Miso I remember.
Oh, it worked!
Ok, we are just like a little mosquito.
Oh!
Get all 18 unique fails in escaping the prison.
Yeah baby!
Which one should we... I like...
I like...
I like the badass bust out.
Can I go here?
Do I have to do it again?
Click.
Oh wait.
Yes!
Click!
I got him.
I'm a pro gamer.
Yeah, pretty much.
I missed some mysterious people, but that's fine.
They will remain mysterious in our hearts.
Nice.
Stealing the diamond.
What is this?
Minecraft?
Open!
Is Henry a bad guy?
Is Henry not a good guy, you think?
He's stealing diamonds now.
Ok, we can bust it.
I feel like I have to say sneak in.
Because I'm like...
It's just part of my branding.
The actual sneak...
So these go up and these go in.
Minecraft Reel!
It actually became Minecraft!
I have a bomb here.
Why would they keep live bombs in a museum?
It's not...well, it's...
It's...
Ok, oh!
Oh wait, there is a plane.
There is a gun.
It's a bird.
It's a plane!
No, it's a gun!
Pretend you were joking.
Ok, it's a plane.
I gotta warn someone.
It's a haunted museum.
Let's go to the retro room.
Retro.
Nice, nice.
Oh my gosh!
It was...
Luigi!
Good ball.
That's a sound.
Pick your reference.
Pretty much.
Let's go with the good ball.
It's not a great ball.
Isn't there like a Pokemon Direct happening soon or something?
Joe!
Go!
Oh no!
Oopsie!
Missing note!
Don't worry about it.
Mushroom!
I have these guys.
Oh my God!
These are antiques!
What the hell?
Guy almost crushed.
Wait, what's happening?
You can click the paintings.
Oh you can!
Oh my God.
I'm leaving this decision up to you Corporal.
Just hit one of those buttons to deal with this pressing situation.
Oh it hurts!
Oh I get to click!
What
is that sound effect from?
I heard it recently I feel.
Oh my God!
Can this ancient wisp who is approaching her late 20's get a B-Day song?
Delina!
Ok, we'll do a quick happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Delina!
Happy birthday!
Don't feel too bad.
He probably camped for the 25 kills he needed to get that nuke.
I feel like I've heard that noise.
I saw some of you guys say Call of Duty, but I feel like I heard it somewhere else recently.
Completely unrelated.
Nuke is from Call of Duty.
I guess they...
It's become a meme.
Fireworks?
Was it the fireworks simulator?
Oh it was!
It was the fireworks simulator!
That's so funny!
What's this?
Oh my gosh, is this dividing by zero?
You can't do that!
It's a surprise if you click the sun and the moon.
Oh think about it.
Thank you!
Where is everyone?
Let's do the satellite.
No!
Oh
gosh!
I just aged 20 years.
I mean do you see your profile picture?
Oh gosh!
This game is such a product of it's time.
Zoomers can't play this game.
They don't understand.
They don't understand!
Oh my god!
Click
on the guy!
What is going on?
What did that do?
We got the thing.
That's not Doomguy actually.
He looks different.
He looks a little different.
Click on the moon.
Nothing happened.
Oh there.
JPE
This one was lame.
2008 was 40 years ago.
This ending... Oh my gosh!
40!
Okay, we'll just try for the... Wait.
We'll just try for the...
What's it called?
A different ending.
Sorry.
I took a nap earlier.
I was so sleepy.
Then I woke up and I had two cats on me.
I was just laying in bed probably until like...
Not very long ago.
Let's go from the beginning since I'm too good at this game.
Anti-gravity cap.
We're going up baby.
Oh no.
I had a feeling.
I've always wanted to go to space.
Space!
Okay, I'm giving the teleporter another try.
It will eventually work.
He looks so nervous every time he uses it.
It worked!
Hell yeah.
Oh, I tried to click him.
Yeah, tranquilize.
Oh my God!
Where did that come from?
Huh?
How?
Falcon punch!
Only one man is capable of that punch.
We were a fool.
The vents?
Oh.
If I woke up with two cats on me, I'd just let that be my whole day so you're stronger than me.
It was very hard.
I'll be honest.
I was like, should I cancel stream?
A penny.
A shiny penny.
I feel like this is the actual answer so I'm going to use the invisibility pill.
What if it shrunk our body and we became a child?
Oh, what happened?
Okay, the penny.
So fast.
Wormhole rifle.
He was so speedy.
Thanks for sharing the pies picture.
It was really cute.
It was her first time ever laying on that pillow.
I was so happy.
I have two foxhound pillows if you didn't see the picture.
I have two foxhound pillows and she laid on one of them.
Well, there was a second one she was kind of on too.
Is this supposed to be like the...
Portal?
Oh, it is a portal.
Why does he sound like this?
Why does Henry sound like such a...
He sounds so wimpy.
It's like...
I'm surprised you weren't able to get down there with that amazing portal technology.
It's pretty strange how those portal guns work.
I mean, it combines the top scientific process of our time.
The portal gun contains a flux quantum generator which propels energy blasts with energy values of 4.3...
Oh, 2.3 GW.
GW.
With an average speed of approximately 25...
What is that?
GW.
Was that the beginning part of the case closed you just sang?
Yeah!
It's not milliseconds.
It would be MS, right?
So this would be meters per second?
The speed is...
25 meters per second feels so fast.
The speed is the most optimal because it allows the energy to be conserved while maintaining...
Oh, wait.
It shoots the thing...
Oh, it shoots the energy blast with a speed of 25 meters per second.
Ah, okay.
I was thinking that...
I don't know.
It allows the energy...
Sorry, guys.
...to be conserved while still maintaining a speed that is appropriate.
The external plastic casing on the portal gun is constructed of a high-polymer fireproof carbon fiber.
This prevents the intense energy of the portal gun from burning the hands of the user.
The intense energy causes intense heat.
Oh, by the way, if you want an achievement, click here.
Yippee!
I have heard that scientists still do not know what happens if two portals are placed on top of each other the last time that was attempted.
Well, I'm sure you heard about that on the news.
Yay!
DLDR.
Okay, we're gonna wire in Mission Impossible.
Actually, I'm just gonna drop in.
I did think it would work.
I did think that would work.
The click achievement is very Homestar Runner core.
Is it right?
Gosh, same era.
It's functional up to 6,000 degrees Kelvin.
Not Kelvin.
Kelvin just sounds like the name of someone in class that you'd be like, Shut up, Kelvin.
Kelvin would always be like, Well, actually, teacher, we had homework last night.
And you'd be like, Shut up, Kelvin.
God, why do you have to remind the teacher about the homework?
It doesn't work.
Laser cutter.
Hammer.
One is very high tech and one is violence.
Oh man, I thought we could get the paintings.
Wait, that actually worked.
It's not...
Tease.
I thought we were...
It had no special properties at all.
I thought we were teasing the game.
Smoking gun.
Diamond, obviously.
Henry, you're a murderer!
A rich murderer.
It's not murder if there's no blood.
True.
Let's see.
Gosh, there's probably...
We didn't get like anything here.
Here, let's try the laser cutter.
This one is fast.
You get cut.
Why you no bleed?
The laser...
Cauterized it.
How did they even explain it?
Wow.
Why you no...
Oh no!
Okay.
Ancient language.
I've seen these runes before.
Hold on.
We need to ask...
It's like... Oh my gosh.
In like 20 years time.
Not even.
Nowadays even you could do this.
You could be like... There's gonna be a movie that shows like...
Why you no bleed?
And they're gonna be like... I don't know.
There's gonna be some like...
Some kids are like... I don't get what it says!
We need to go ask grandpa!
And grandpa is like sitting in chair in his like...
Lounge at home.
And he's just there like...
Grandpa, we found these ancient texts.
We need you to decipher them.
And he like reads it and it's just like...
Shoop da whoop.
And then he has that Ratatouille moment.
And he's like...
And then he's just like...
A single tear runs down his cheek.
And he's like...
I haven't seen this.
Where did you find this?
You kids nowadays only know Skibbity Riz.
But...
Shoop da whoop.
Walked so Skibbity could run.
It's been...
He's gotta say...
It's been 84 years.
What is bro saying?
Like okay grandpa.
Actual okay grandpa moment.
This one we did...
Most of them.
This one, we didn't do this one.
It's like...
This...
Oh this heads to the...
This heads to the retro room and this heads straight to the diamond.
Must be a light sleeper.
She's cracked the code.
Scatter!
I take why you know over Skibbity any day of the week.
That just means you've matured baby.
I don't know actually.
We missed one here.
What did I miss here?
I got the bomb.
Oh I think I have to run out of time.
I just wanted to get to know each other a little bit.
I just kind of wanted to have a conversation.
Just lighten things up.
They are like having their own little conversation.
What's going on?
Okay.
Oh the portrait!
Sorry.
It's okay.
I'm more interested in getting the endings than getting all the bios.
Wait can I even get Luigi?
No.
Alien.
I got one out of thirty.
There's thirty of them?
Get headcrabbed.
We did...
The mushroom and the ball.
We did not do the crowbar.
We expect so many memories.
This is actual headcrab.
Sorry the other one was not the headcrab.
These are the actual headcrabs.
What's the other one from?
Metroid?
Metroid.
I knew it.
Okay let's see.
This is the beginning one.
We still...
Okay we did the teleporter.
We did this.
Oh we did the anti-gravity.
Jumbo hoppers.
There he goes.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Wait what is that a reference to?
Do it two more times.
Wait actually...
Pilotwings64.
Sweet flip bro.
Minus four.
It didn't say anything different though.
2008 was seventeen years ago.
Oh wait.
Map.
Sorry.
What are we trying?
Trinket.
Oh we can go through the little crack.
There we go.
Look how small he is.
Yeah, actually 2020 was twenty years ago.
How do you feel about that now?
Do you feel old?
Liquidificator.
So true.
Ten out of ten.
It's a fantastically easy to use gadget game.
I trust that guy with my life.
We turned into human liquid.
Take that for what you will.
Okay, this one we had the canon that we still needed to do.
Earlier today I had to hold myself back from saying can I has cheeseburger when I was working at McDonald's.
I came to this dream for silly deaths and references not existential dread.
No!
The can I has cheeseburger.
Sometimes I say that though as unironically and I'm afraid that one day I'll say...
You know when you say things unironically?
Like for the bit and then it becomes part of your actual vernacular and you're just like oh no I don't think it's a bit anymore.
Wait I'm doing this for real?
You say it as a joke until it becomes... yeah like my cats.
Because you know everybody does like that pet talk.
You know like the way you speak to your animals like to your pets is like different.
And so I'll be like...
He says can I has cheeseburger.
Like so stupid.
You guys don't talk to your pets weird?
I have full conversations with my pets.
Like the way Butaro speaks.
I know how I think he's actually... I feel like he's projecting his thoughts into my brain.
And then I have a full conversation and he'll be like...
He'll be like...
Oh I'm cold.
I'll be like you need to lay in the blanket then.
He's like no I don't wanna.
I don't know.
It always just comes to...
I can't recreate it.
It's something that comes to me in the moment.
Because you are insane.
No I'm not!
I'm not!
It's the meds.
It's the meds talking.
No!
Everybody does this with their pets.
What is the unique things your cat can do?
Nothing.
He sucks.
I like how she's doing the nostalgia thing in-game without even playing.
Shut up!
Thank you guys for all the superchats.
Talking.
Schizo arc.
No!
Can I get a late two day birthday from you?
I can sing happy birthday!
Sorry for being late.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday IDK.
Happy birthday.
Please cease this immediately for your own reputation.
I know someone at work who says alright chat we need to chill and mods ban them.
But at one point does it stop being cringe and starts becoming iconic.
Right?
At one point are you like oh no this guy is so iconic.
The cringe to iconic circle is very...
So cringe it warps back.
Right?
There's two sides of the same coin I believe.
I'm sending this to you.
It's not my birthday.
I won't sing you happy birthday then.
My cat says it's perfectly normal to talk to cats.
Maybe I'm just lonely.
I don't know.
I don't talk to many people.
I talk to you guys.
That's why if I don't stream for a day I become all pent up with yappy energy.
I talk to nobody.
Anyway, we need to do the cannon.
Oh I got the painting.
Oh it fell.
Oh gosh.
Come on Henry.
It worked.
Ending there's another route at the start.
It's okay you guys seriously.
I probably won't get everything.
Like this one, yeah I see how it is.
I see it.
For endings I don't...
mind trying to get them all but if I'm like okay let's move on then I will just move on.
That's the toxoplasmosis talking.
You know what?
And I love that.
I loved being toxic.
I love being toxic.
But we'll get this one.
Because I want to snap his neck.
What if I just jump on him?
I'm just going to jump on him.
I'm surprised we made it that far with the heavy diamond.
Why didn't we jump on top of him?
What?
Snap neck.
I told you man.
I told you about stairs.
What is...Is this a...Oh gosh.
I know the stairs meme but I don't actually know what it's from.
Is it a Homestuck thing?
I warned you about the stairs bro or whatever.
What is it from?
It is a Homestuck reference?
I've never read Homestuck.
I never read it.
I literally know...I know that they're grey and that they have...
What's it called?
They have like Capricorn symbols for their names or whatever.
I never read it.
Oh well.
Oh, whoops.
Wait.
OK, we'll get the rifle one.
I was just going to keep going but...
Put your hands up!
This is literally me playing any FPS.
Man, those first person shooters make it look so easy.
How could you miss?
He was right in front of you.
OK, this was the...
This was the unseen burglar and just plain epic.
We'll go with the unseen burglar.
OK, so wait.
How do I...
Go to here.
Wait.
Or should we try this one?
We'll try this one because we are here.
Damn it Rio.
True.
It's not me.
It's Rio.
Cats are the best conversation partners.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Jump.
Did that work?
Jumping off a spinning vehicle.
We're going to ram.
How?
How recent is this game?
Isn't Dot Boy pretty recent all things considered?
Basket.
It's kind of heavy though.
There we go.
I thought this game was from 2005.
2016.
No, I feel like... Compared to Shoop Da Whoop?
Compared to Shoop Da Whoop?
That meme is way more recent than Shoop Da Whoop.
Excuse me?
It came out in 2020.
Oh, they updated some stuff for the remake.
OK, OK.
You can't be like...
Oh mint.
Oh my gosh.
That boy was so old.
No, compared to the other memes in here...
It's my birthday but can I get a baby got back instead of happy birthday?
Sure!
Baby got back!
The book...
They are talking about the same thing as before.
Happy Birthday!
Oh my God!
Rock!
Upside down!
Boss, get down!
Oh my God, we are killing it.
I'm too good at this game!
I'm bribing him?
I deserve a fair trial!
That boy was a decade ago.
Enjoy the psychic damage.
You guys are so stupid.
You are twisting my words.
Drive!
OK, one more.
Diamond.
That guy was just going to shoot me regardless.
OK, we made it!
We made it?
Intruder on a scooter.
Alright, we are just going to go from here.
Because there is...oh wait.
Nevermind, I thought there was 20 more that we would have to do.
But we got all the endings so we are good.
Amogus.
This is the Amogus area.
The Toppat Clan.
Was that me?
Wait, I remember Charlie!
It's up to you.
Find a way to bring him down and you'll be a free man.
Sticky hand!
Yo, that worked.
That worked.
Oh my gosh, I hate this thing in Amogus.
Ball and chain.
I think I did it though.
I stole their money.
Wait, this is actually working.
I spedrun.
No!
It's still a fail.
I was too good.
Zero point...but we don't want that.
We don't want this, right?
Wait, I need to get out of here because...
Wait...
Do I go back here?
Oh 2 out of 2, yeah.
Cannonball earpiece.
OK.
Oh, C4 baby.
And...blow up!
We stick to what we know.
Nevermind.
We can knock.
We can...
Excuse me!
Hello!
They probably would have let you in if you had Girl Scout cookies.
I was thinking like yesterday.
I was like, I want thin mints.
I want thin mints so bad!
When do the Girl Scouts sell the cookies?
OK.
The vacuum is clearly the answer.
What is it sucking up?
Hang on.
Disgusting.
I got him!
Disguise?
Glue?
Or Transdimensionalizer.
What does this do?
Visit alternate dimensions with the flick of a switch.
It's super easy to use and gives awesome results.
I'd trust that guy with my life.
We went to the first dimension!
Oh my gosh!
That's even beyond me!
I'm two dimensions!
Let's flip the switch up to get back to it.
Alright.
That's 1D debut.
Glue.
I don't like the sound.
Oh my gosh!
Among us sounds.
Yes please!
Tails!
Or Charles.
I like Tails.
Get out!
Oh god.
Mind control.
Bone melt?
Oh my gosh!
Thank you!
Wait that actually worked!
Spook him!
I can't believe that worked again.
I'm speed running.
I'm too good at this!
I'm too good at this you guys.
Oh gosh.
I don't need your help.
We made it.
Oh great.
Awesome.
Make animal noise.
Wow I didn't die though.
Reroute the power.
Because if we shut off the power the whole thing is gonna...
You're gonna kill a bunch of people.
That's fine.
We killed his hobby.
We killed his hopes and his dreams.
Just jump.
You'll make it.
Oh nevermind.
Just trust your instincts Henry!
Banana.
Banana!
What is this a reference to?
Worms?
Oh I don't know if I played worms.
What?
There was worms...
Something right?
Recently?
Click on the banana?
Click the red text?
What happened?
Sleeping gas.
Good job Charles.
You snooze you lose.
What?
The last one is a force gun.
See ya.
That was so smooth.
Rank government supported private investigator.
Infamous Top Hat clan has been apprehended.
Hundreds of arrests made.
Many still at large.
Authorities tipped off by anonymous source.
1 out of... Oh my gosh 60 fails.
1 out of 4 unique endings.
We can go back.
Let's see.
Look at this.
I was too good.
I was way too good at this game.
Wait, there is even more here that we didn't do.
Let's try the cannonball.
That's us?
Oh you can see the shot.
This guy is dead.
Laser!
Oh, just kidding.
It's fine.
We were in a ball.
Newton's third law.
I don't... I don't... I've never read physics!
Oh yeah.
Super monkey ball.
Yeah, if you don't read you never have to worry about it.
Oh my gosh.
Spikes!
Wait, I don't think that will help us.
Defensive mode.
Good move.
Good choice.
Eject!
Nice!
Run, run, run Henry!
Matrix... Metal Fist!
Punch, punch, punch!
Oh,
I thought you were an actual spammer.
Sorry, I put you in timeout because I thought you were spamming.
Please don't spam.
Please don't... You guys, I'm... You can see that I'm getting to the... I'm getting most, if not all the endings, so...
Try not to spam for stuff for me to do.
Thank you.
I'm not even gonna pick the beans.
Sorry.
Oh, I have to pick the beans.
You got lucky this time, I guess.
No more quick time events.
Oops,
I forgot to get that guy.
You guys spammed my chat over a fart joke?
Over a fart joke?
That's what you wanted to see so badly?
And it was the only answer I could do to move forward.
So I would have had to pick it.
Oh my god.
I'm talking to the... Sorry, I know there's like a bunch of people here.
More than the four people that...
That spammed the chat.
It was all such... So many spammers in such a short amount of time.
You wouldn't get it.
This is too high-Q.
This is too much.
How could you not understand the perfect comedic genius that was the fart joke of the beans?
I thought we were gonna get like a true... This was like a worse...
What's his name?
Oh my gosh.
The guy that eats the spinach.
Popeye!
I thought we were gonna get a Popeye moment.
Metal bend.
With our psychic energy.
Oh yeah!
Too much bend.
We are... You are a bender Harry.
Robo pants.
Yeah, kick his ass!
I forgot to wear the harness.
Oh Henry, you are so pathetic.
I keep forgetting I got this guy.
Yo-yo!
Bash!
Henry attacks!
500!
Oh my god, no Henry!
How did you die so badly?
What did you expect hitting him with a yo-yo would do?
I guess we'll use...
You either pick one game or the other.
Magic!
Reflect.
Oh he does reflect.
I do fire.
Wait, Henry no!
Let's go back to Final Fantasy.
What tools we got?
Chainsaw!
What's happening?
Hello?
Unpack a chainsaw.
Should have kept you locked up.
Glider jet boots.
Here is our Popeye's mode.
Oh shit!
This is what Popeye has to do every time he inflates his arms.
The glider seems too safe.
Something is going to happen.
Oh no!
I missed that one guy against the wall.
He was looking so cool.
Dummies?
What the?
We trapped them!
You think they are alright?
Pretty big fall.
I'm sure Henry had a plan.
We double crossed him!
I'm the big cheese now!
OK, let's see.
But that's not canon, is it?
Of the Henry lore.
It's not canon.
Is there going to be one more branch down here?
Oh wait, 0 out of 2.
Wait, where is the tank?
It's technically canon.
All endings are canon.
Oh it's the Newgrounds tank!
No way!
Yeah, take him.
What is this?
Jefferson Smithsonian!
We are free!
Wow!
Relentless Bounty Hunter!
2013?
Wait, what?
Is that what it said?
The pardon said 2013.
2013.
All crimes prior to 2013.
What year is it?
Everybody change the clocks on your computer!
We can all pretend it's 2013 today.
I mean, this game makes me feel that way anyway.
It's still...
Oh I see!
So if I...
That's why there is the top hat and the little general hat here.
So if I do this, it's on their side.
If I do this, it's on their side.
I see!
Oh damn!
Just that shot took down the entire plane?
OK.
Parachute.
This will definitely have the parachute in it though.
100%
Oopsie.
Butterfingers.
Oh no, Henry!
Let's see, what are these ones that I spedrun?
Then there is even more here.
We didn't do the grapple gun.
This is weird!
You do the phone.
What's a joy buzzer?
See ya.
Expanding phone.
Oh OK.
I think it said do not shake.
I don't see that.
I literally can't read.
We're gonna wait.
OK, I'm sure.
I got it.
I got his ass.
Oh damn that worked.
I got a key!
What does that do?
Computer, elevator, vent?
Wait is this...it's not actually me.
Incriminating evidence?
Civ 5!
No!
Henry!
OK This is in true Among Us fashion.
We are venting.
Oh yeah, too real.
Oh we made it to the records!
Oh nevermind, we want to get to the other side.
OK, the teleporter will be real this time.
Got a sense of that SpongeBob world.
Future!
Stretch Chewies.
This makes me want some though.
Sounds yummy.
Oh!
Oh god!
It really grinds my gears.
Magic Pencil?
OK
Why did you draw a nut shot?
Why would you create...why is there a thing called a nut shot crawler?
Why does that even exist?
I guess we are leaping.
Leap of faith baby!
Oh I got this guy.
That's right.
Can we let him out?
I got the key!
Oh my god!
You're welcome!
Wizard magic!
I know one...oh we rolled a one.
I was gonna say we know one spell.
Dang it.
Paperizer?
Oh it turns us into paper?
Or we are hacking.
What are you doing?
We got lol jumpscared.
It's quite shocking.
I'm glad it's not in your current...
Oh wait.
I'm glad I'm not in your current situation.
I bet you can't wait to go...
lol everybody lol I feel like the paperizer is the correct answer so I'm gonna do the retro glove.
You look like an idiot.
They got our bad side.
Oh no!
There he goes.
How did he make it?
Who the hell was that?
Gravity manipulator.
Wait, that one launches.
It happened so fast I didn't even see what happened.
Shrink and grow.
We can make it teeny tiny.
Nice.
Oh, I can get these guys.
Oopsie.
What?
We almost got sliced and diced in here.
What's the armor?
Is this doomed?
We're Naruto running though.
What the hell?
Oh, it's Fallout.
Okay.
I was gonna say, what the hell?
Totally doomed.
Yeah, this is doomed.
I mean...
lol
Okay.
Yeah, I saw a spy out there.
Oh, what's this one?
Looks suspicious.
Suspicious.
Oh, oh no!
That's why I was suspicious?
Oopsie.
Could not find C program files.
Half-Life 3 not found.
Pro...Deb.
Sounds sexy.
That anus thief.
Goodbye
Deb.
Why did you choose that?
Oh, that's so sad.
Okay.
L cut mark 2.
Laser.
Yeah, we can just steal it.
There it goes.
We can just take the ground.
Take our problems and push them somewhere else.
Exactly!
Do you feel like a hero?
Yeah, I am the hero.
I'm the main character!
Oh, I missed one.
Sorry.
I was too slow.
Oh, I got him.
There he is.
He's got the ruby.
Oh,
are you just going to leave that there?
I will take that and I will escape.
Let me through.
What is Ken?
Let me through!
That's so true.
But what about our pardon though?
You're blooded thief!
We got all four.
Oh my gosh, we still have half of the unique fails though.
There are so many in this game.
How many storylines are like... This is what?
Hold on, I'm just going to go to the menu.
Oh wait, this is it?
Is it just two left?
OK, we can do the other things for this one then.
Oh wait, can I skip?
Skip, skip, skip.
What do we need to do here?
We'll go with the first one.
I did glue.
And did I do this one?
I think so.
We did not do the disguise.
Go ahead.
Don't worry.
I'll tell the chief.
OK.
Bye!
Happy Father's Day!
I wasn't ready to be a dad.
Oh God.
OK.
This one, yeah.
We can do...we'll do Charles last.
Family.
Why do they even have this?
They have...how do they get across?
Why do they even have this gravity bubble?
As a prank.
You got this Charles.
So wait, does up increase gravity or does it lift you up in the air?
That's such a good question, actually.
I think it was being repaired.
Possibly.
Alright Charles, do your best or your worst.
Alright Charles!
Charles is here!
He looks so excited to be here.
He's like I'm in the mission too!
Alright, we did the RoboHut.
Let's go to the next thing.
We did the Bone Melt which I...
I'm really happy that that worked.
Let's do the Gatling Gun.
Hold on, I'm gonna...
Since I can't stop coughing.
Cough drop.
Didn't even hit the door.
The guy was like...dead tongue out body.
So silly.
Mind control!
Controlling another person is harder than it looks.
Skill issue Charles.
Sorry.
Who was doing the mind control?
We're hacking.
Wrong subroutine.
Is Minto a master manipulator?
I will possess him.
This used to be a flash game.
I know.
I know, I know.
Next, this one.
Oh yeah, this one is...
Fraud?
Oh gosh.
I'm gonna let it run out of time first.
Charlie is the Pequod of this game.
I know, he's so cute!
This is a good time Charles!
We're supposed to be sneaky!
It's the same thing just flipped.
I wonder what's over here.
Espionage, we have a lot of fraud, espionage, research...
Probably members birthdays.
Poor duck.
Yeah, poor duck.
Ninja style!
You missed!
This
is literally...
This is literally what I'm saying all the time.
You missed!
How could you miss?
It was the refrain of my...
Oh my gosh.
But when I say it...
Yeah, dishonor on you!
Yeah, I'm always quoting Mushu from Mulan.
You missed!
It's the part when Mulan...
When... What's his name?
Oh gosh.
The bad guy is coming at Mulan.
And...
And she shoots the rocket.
But he was right there.
Dishonor on you!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
She shoots it.
And Mushu is on it.
He's like, you missed!
Yeah, the mountain scene, exactly!
Yeah, she causes the avalanche instead of hitting him.
And kills him.
Mulan is so fun.
I love quoting that scene.
Falcon kick!
I think you put too much energy into it that time.
What's the balance?
No energy and we don't do anything.
Too much energy and we get that.
The Huns, Mulan.
The Huns.
OK, I think that's all of them there.
Let's turn off the ship, baby!
Let's hope the landing gear still has power.
Alrighty, and that's all of them for that round.
Look at us, we're too good.
Now this one.
What?
OK, we did the laser?
I think.
Did we not do the thruster?
I thought we would have more thrust.
Thruster?
I hardly even know her.
You know, I really expected you to go faster with those thrusters.
OK, we got 2 of 2 there.
So here...
Boost!
Gotta go fast!
That was a lack of thrust.
Miento!
Sorry.
I had to!
The joke was right.
What do you mean negative 2?
That was a good one.
Eject!
Oh wait!
I forgot what scene we were in.
Wait!
I did it!
I did it correctly.
I'm too good at the game.
OK, we can go back now.
Here we go.
Dang it!
I did the same thing!
I have to let it run out of time.
Here we go.
Bounce!
Oh that thing was colossal!
Oh is that a face?
I thought it was underpants.
Huh?
I think these are eyebrows and these are eyes and then it's laughing.
It looks like underpants though, doesn't it?
Same?
It looks like underpants!
Oopsie!
OK, we got all those.
Oh this one!
This one will be good because there are so many.
Actually I'm going to save it.
We'll save it as the last thing.
Jet boots.
Still a ponzo expert.
Jet books... Jet books?
Jet boots?
Production notes.
Find lighter material to construct boots out of.
Nice.
Alright.
We shall do the Final Fantasy so far.
Jet books.
Combine boots and production.
Like Captain Underpants?
Yeah!
Like Captain Underpants.
Bombs?
Ripperoni.
Out of all those options you chose fight?
How boring.
Only for the 100%.
What is Blitz?
Suplex?
Chain Gun!
Oh come on!
I thought for sure that would have done it.
OK, now we just need to go... We do the Heal Heal.
Yeah, we lost elite amount of points.
Amount of elite damage.
It worked on the train.
I like these discount versions of the songs.
They are pretty good though.
What did I do before?
Defend?
I think I did.
Let's do goods.
Multi-bottle rocket!
Good BGM.
No,
I can't say that I've played Earthbound before, I'll be honest.
But obviously I know the reference.
Let's go back.
It's a PSA.
Mint is redacted.
No!
Why would you say that?
To my face?
How dare you!
Auto fight.
Bash!
Oh wait, did I do that one before?
I don't remember.
So we got to do defend and saw.
I could not stop crying.
Henry cannot take a single hit, Gennie.
Oh Henry, I'd be crying if you flashed me too.
Yes,
Gennie.
So are they!
Defend.
Swung wildly.
Oh my god!
Mortal damage!
Oh my god, Henry!
Henry can't take a hit.
The best offense is a good defense.
Somebody unsuccessful.
You know what?
That's how I always played my games, baby.
My things would be total offense.
Like in Pokemon, if something was just like...
Oh this gives you more...
You know, like Harden or something.
Nah, only fight.
No defend.
Only fight, no defend.
This one we didn't do.
I was too good at this one too.
Here we go.
Bomb!
What?
Should've used the remote, but it worked though!
Bomberman.
That game stresses me out.
Bomberman stresses me out.
So when they were like, oh yeah, Bomberman and new Metal Gear Delta.
I was just like, oh gosh.
Because you have to ride around so fast and everything.
I'm scared.
But the girls in it...
are great.
We didn't use the elevator before.
These sound effects make me want to play...
They make me want to play Among Us.
Should've sworn that was an elevator.
This one we didn't do.
The claw pack.
What is this a reference to?
Take care of your bird.
Oh Banjo.
Banjo Kazooie.
Oh wait.
Ok.
Outer wing.
We did the armor.
We fall out of shells.
Get green shelled.
Nevermind.
Wait, what?
Get green shelled?
Henry!
I'll tell you what.
Oh my gosh.
Ok, you guys.
I saw a video the other day.
I don't remember what the context was.
But I was listening to it.
And I was like, gosh.
The girl talking in this sounds like Doki.
I was like, she sounds like Doki so much.
And then I was reading the comments.
And the comments were just like...
They were making reference saying that the girl sounded like Bobby Hill.
And I was like...
Does Bobby sound like...
Wait, does Doki sound like Bobby?
And now...
I wanna... Hold on.
I'm gonna go listen to... Let's see.
I'm gonna pull up a video.
Ok.
Bobby Hill.
Let's just say... Him saying anything.
This is...
This is best of Bobby Hill from Adult Swim.
I'm just gonna listen to him say one thing, ok?
Ok, he's not...
When he talks, we'll know.
Ok, sorry you can't see it.
I'm too lazy to pull it up for you guys.
You'll just have to sound only.
Talk, Bobby!
That's just a Doki clip you're playing.
Oh no!
Wait, I'm gonna skip.
Ok, let's skip to like here.
If Doki had a southern accent...
I discovered this like... It was like a couple of weeks ago.
And I was like, I have to... I have to tell everybody this.
I completely forgot.
Now I bestow this cursed knowledge upon you.
It's like Doki's sister is what it sounds like.
We have Doki at home.
I didn't know Doki was a guest on this stream too.
Have you told her?
No.
I didn't.
Ok, let's do the umbrella.
A little kid in a mask from FF10-2 has the same VA as Bobby Hill.
A little kid in a mask?
I don't remember that kid.
Merry Poppins!
Oh god, Merry Poppins!
We got all the fails.
Shinra?
Oh, Shinra!
I was like, what the heck?
Kid in a mask?
I remember Shinra, yeah.
Yay, we got everything!
We didn't get all the people, but that's ok.
Oh my gosh, I got a lot of them.
Never mind.
No, I didn't.
I thought I did.
Wait!
That's Dave Papa.
For one reason or another, he's been captured by the Top Hat Clan and now sits in their brig.
Bordecai Booker.
Kurt Steele.
Mert Steele.
Otoho, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Oh, there we go.
Kent and Ryu.
I love Ryu.
That guy.
Handsome Harold!
What makes him so handsome?
Hatchman.
Plumb.
Wait, Plumb.
Oh no, he's Pampa.
He's pretty handsome.
Sir Wilford.
Suave.
What the hell?
TRNK, a failed experiment in resurrecting a long dead leader.
Didn't last long before he turned on everyone.
Mint, have you seen House MD?
I have.
I have seen House MD.
Why?
Drunk.
Nice!
Now we can go...
What was that?
I don't remember what my favorite ending was for this.
I think it was the...
True Thief?
One, I think.
Billy G, not my lover.
The Newgrounds Tank.
Which one was that?
This one?
Wait, which one was it?
It wasn't the banana.
No, it was the force...
It wasn't this one.
It's ok.
We already got the other one.
This one is so smooth though.
It's kind of awesome.
It's kind of awesome, I'm not going to lie.
This is the one where we get pardoned, right?
Nice.
Alright, let's go on to the next one.
Fleeing the Complex.
We need Bobby Ducky Hill fanart now.
I know, right?
The wall.
We got pardoned!
Shadow Moses.
No!
I didn't get...
I got him.
Do not...
What does it say though?
I'm going to play dead.
It's Grigori.
Grigori!
Can you imagine?
Thank God his name is not Gustav.
Put him with others.
Ok.
No!
Fried Tofu time!
Welcome to my machine.
Thank you.
I don't remember the girl's name.
We're going to boost up.
Give me up there.
Give me up there girl.
Come on.
What the hell?
Go Henry!
Oh my God!
Oh yeah!
Wait, what's this?
Come on with!
Riz a hundred.
Oh I...
I don't care.
Watching House for the first time is good.
Yeah, I like it.
Is this the one?
It worked though.
It worked.
I suppose.
There it is.
The distraction dance.
Oh my gosh my title.
What?
Sounds like something a Sim would say.
Bounce Bros.
Oh gosh!
We're not the Bounce Bros!
I was about to say something not so nice about her.
But I don't know.
We can never be them.
They have too much coordination.
Tall guy!
Oh yeah my favorite.
Hey buddy!
Please say it.
You know the saying Bros before Hoes.
We couldn't be the Bounce Bros.
Minus two.
I know!
That's why I didn't say it!
Gosh!
You can't say minus two when you told me to say it!
Little Savage welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Nice to meet you.
If we can get you up there, you can get in and open this door.
We're gonna use the force.
Oh god!
She's gonna use the force.
OK That worked, I think.
Wait, that actually worked?
Oh, they are too fast!
They are too fast!
I can't grab them.
How did that work?
Sniper Rifle!
One each and she gets a taser.
Hey, I just grabbed these.
Maybe they will come in handy.
How am I so good at this game?
Oh my god!
We're gonna blend in obviously.
Hold the elevator?
Thanks.
Can you believe this inmate operate?
Crazy, huh?
Yes, it is pretty crazy.
Oh yeah, we transferred from the 8th floor.
No!
Not the extra down!
Oh my god, get LA noired.
I love that that's still like a funny thing.
Like extra down is still funny to me.
Just like F to pay respects.
I feel like people don't say F very much anymore though.
The extra down to me at least feels like it hasn't been overused.
You know what I mean?
Like in an unfunny way.
But F kind of fell off, yeah.
F to pay respects.
F for F to pay respects.
No!
Yeah, F evolved to 07.
So true, so true.
Venue!
Welcome to Vanbusha, thank you.
Every letter is a meme now.
True.
What's meme is for?
Oh wait, I was gonna say W.
But it is a meme!
For...
J.
What about J, huh?
We should, ok guys, let's make J into a funny thing that people type.
We can do it.
We can start the J movement.
Something happens in chat, you just...
J for Jork!
Jorking.
No, not Jorking it.
No!
No, no, no.
Who is J-Don?
What is J-Don?
J for Jorking.
J-Don my soul.
I don't know it.
Oh it's a bae meme.
Ah, ok, ok.
I don't know it.
Happy for you though.
Let's see.
Latosh?
Oh my God!
No!
We ratted them out.
Oh gosh, there are so many guys here.
Oh God!
Oh gosh, is this gonna be like a thing to the knee?
Make a face!
It worked!
I'm too good at this game.
We can go to that guy.
No, this looks...we can...
Wait, is that a bike?
Yeah, take the bike.
No!
She'll come back for me.
I think I'm always too good at this game.
Five endings!
Ok, alright.
Let's start getting some of these other things.
Oh my gosh, I literally only just went down one path.
What if I didn't grab her though?
Oh no!
Ellie!
You are now imagining long-haired Vincent Evangelion plucks you.
I don't care.
Command Melody?
I don't really appreciate that one very much.
Wind Waker.
I never actually got to play Wind Waker.
It was for...
Wind Waker is good.
Gamecube!
I didn't have a Gamecube.
I didn't have a Gamecube, you guys.
That's why.
I was like, I think it was not on a platform that I had.
I only had a Gamecube like recently.
I got it for...
I got it for Twin Snakes.
I only got my Gamecube for Twin Snakes.
Like very, very recently.
So...
Unfortunately... Oh wait.
Pickpocket!
I ended up buffing up my...
Wait!
I'm taking everything.
Oh no!
Actual Skyrim moment.
Did you really need all that?
No loot left behind.
I was told recently to play Skyrim.
I was like, I think you'll like it.
Maybe.
Let's just run.
Was that the convict?
No...
That was just to win.
But I'm a loot goblin.
You guys know that.
Fake shoot him?
Oh, I thought he said fake shoot him.
Like they weren't actually gonna shoot me.
Ah, I see, I see.
Wait, did we get 3 out of 3 here?
Oh, of the wrong things, yeah.
Oh, whoopee cushion with a rock!
He's strangling that guy out.
He's choking him out.
How do we get up there by ourselves?
We use the force.
Power jump?
Power jump.
Hell yeah!
Oh yeah!
This will work for sure.
How does this actually work?
We tried the plunger boots before, or rather we did the plungers before.
Helium.
Oh yeah!
Oh my gosh, Henry, you can do it.
Why didn't he just crawl across?
Wait, is that actually it?
Oh my god, are you kidding me?
Wait!
Just a box.
No!
Wait, this is so messed up.
I wish this actually would happen instead.
Not gonna lie.
Shadowser?
The unseen stick is the deadliest.
Blend in.
Become a shadow.
I'm gonna be honest with you, this one isn't that great.
Gotcha game!
No!
What are you talking about?
This one might be the most powerful.
Oh oh, just kidding.
Oh god.
Clicking the red shadow here doesn't do anything.
Now you are but a shadow of your former self.
Mario!
Whatever works, works, right?
A dingy?
A rocket?
SS Annie.
SS Annie!
What's going on with SS Annie?
Did you think none of the crew would notice an unscheduled departure?
Living Neutral, thank you so much for 10 months!
So funny.
Let's see.
Let's go on the rocket.
That's how all my rockets start.
Oh jeez.
OK.
Yeah, we're fine.
I felt like the dingy would be the option, but...
Someone just leave.
I think it was Smith.
Probably off to see his family.
Welcome
to Family Shipping!
Nice.
Nice and nice.
Alright.
I don't even know which way do we go to get other endings.
It must be through here, right?
To branch out the endings.
I guess we'll start here.
Judo throw.
Oh, nevermind.
That was so fast.
We used the force before, so we'll use the gravity tool.
From the beginning?
Oh really?
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted!
From the beginning here?
Oh, wait for transfer.
Alright, let's go.
It's been a while.
Have a good time.
Thank you!
Fake illness.
Teleporter's gotta work this time.
It's gotta.
Wow!
GG!
No!
RE?
What does that mean?
What is this?
Starcraft?
Get out of here.
Oh no, rematch.
That's messed up!
Cookie.
Resident Evil.
How curious.
Oh let's...
I have COVID.
Oh gosh, we are here with all the sickies.
Ahoy!
Oh my god.
Let's see.
Laser plane?
That looks like it will work.
Government?
Top Hat clan.
Government.
Charlie!
I got pardoned, but I'm still in jail.
The wall.
Can you come here?
Yeah, I don't mind.
Nice!
Look at all these guys we just grabbed.
Earthbend.
I'm too good at this.
Oh no, he can't take a hit.
Wait!
Why did it become GTA?
We were doing so well.
Why?
Oh I can flash him!
I don't really have any clothes on anyway.
Don't cross the references.
I see the wall.
Oh you are outside?
Nice.
I'm right down there.
Oh him!
OK Charles, go for it.
He
is so cute.
What about a mini tiny baby helicopter?
Yeah, deploy the baby!
He will be like a little mosquito.
Such a nuisance.
Or a death trap.
OK
Him?
Yeah!
Get him!
Oh damn!
Perfection.
Yeah!
3 out of 5.
I don't know if I'll get all the unique fails for this one because holy cow...
There are so many, but I do want to get more of the...
Like look at this.
I got perfect 3 times in a row.
I'm kind of cracked.
But...
Does this...
Oh phone a friend.
This will branch off one of them at least.
One of the endings at least.
What?
A wall?
OK I think long hair Minto is the smart one.
What are you talking about?
I'm still regular.
Yeah, yeah I'm right here.
Yup.
How do we...
Undercover.
Wait, would they not know who I am then?
Let's do a neurotoxin.
What is...Oh there it is.
Oh did they forget to hand out your gas mask beforehand?
Oopsie.
I don't know what the...What's with the drill pot even?
Let's do undercover agent.
He spent 3 years undercover.
How did they know that I was going to be here?
What is this?
What is this setup that they were planning for?
OK, drill pot I guess.
God, loud.
Get to the airship.
Slingshot.
Click here for a medal.
Oh, you gotta work for it.
Still seems too easy.
I'm up here now.
I'm down here now.
How did this happen?
Shrug.
This seems like a good spot to be.
Sure.
How's it going?
Fine.
Doing the game so far?
Yeah.
I'm glad.
No problem.
So what should we talk about?
I bet you don't know the capital of Mongolia off the top of your head.
I bet you're just pressing OK without even reading what I'm reading.
This is important.
Don't skip my words.
Dogs have feet.
Press the sun in the sneaky ending.
What?
Why?
I got tired of that spot.
Good.
This seems nicer maybe.
Which one is correct?
This.
You guessed it right!
I have a confession though.
What?
They were both correct.
Will you press the rightmost button?
No.
You liar!
Don't press this button.
OK.
Sneaky ending, huh?
What was the sneaky ending?
Was it this one?
Sneak.
Sneaky.
Skip.
Wait, can I skip a skip?
Oh the prison.
This one?
Oh yeah, that's right.
It was this one.
Skip.
What was the sneaky ending?
Yeah.
I remember.
It was the plungers.
There is no sun!
Ah!
Nevermind, I got it.
Nevermind.
Was it worth it?
We didn't do the charge tackle, did I?
Speedjuice!
Sonic!
Too fast for you.
ZeroYangster, welcome to Mammoth Gaming!
Oh wait, retry?
I'm scared.
Item!
Miiiine!
Where is it?
Sir, I got a message.
Yes, go ahead.
Yeah, it looks like Henry Stickman.
Stickman?
Yeah, Henry Stickman has escaped.
Me too.
Maybe I can win though.
Tank?
Oh I'm fighting the tank?
Stickmans don't belong in Alaska?
Where are we?
This guy...they both look menacing.
Let's go to the building.
No!
Freddy's Fazbear!
No way!
OK, oh gosh.
TKO
We got punch out.
Wait, I gotta get this guy in my...there we go.
Alright, to here?
Oh
my God!
We just murdered him!
Oops He's up here somewhere.
Huskwin!
Welcome to my bushes!
Costume
These guys need to chill.
No way!
They killed Frosty?
What is Frosty?
OK, what is he in for?
What could Frosty...
Why?
You don't wanna know.
Tax evasion?
War crimes.
A sandwich.
This happens to me too everytime I eat a sandwich.
Not that though.
I always win.
Castle Crashers.
Oh really?
Wait, TF2?
Castle Crashers?
I thought I played that before.
Horizontal.
Now welcome.
Thank you for the 10 gift cards.
Thank you so much!
They hate you.
Kinda both I guess.
This one weird trick will make you super buff.
Weightlifters hate him!
Frosty is probably in for arson.
No!
I believe that.
I believe that actually.
Fail!
See ya!
Oh wait, I think...
I committed.
I committed and I regretted it.
Dictator Cherry!
Welcome to the membership.
So many new members today!
Thank you guys!
Alright, we got this time.
We got this time.
Oh shoot!
Eyes on the road buddy!
Slam!
Jam!
Japan!
I'm gonna wait it out first.
Oh airbag.
Surrender.
More things are showing up.
That's so interesting.
See ya!
OK No way!
No way!
The patience test.
What?
Oh my gosh we are in...
It's a...
Glory to Artstotzka!
We got papers pleased.
There is still one more ending.
Oh my gosh, we have only just reached half the unique fails.
I wanna try...
Not the helipad.
The one we just did.
The cliffside wreck.
I wanna see what the other ones do in this part.
Since you just kind of waited it out.
Oh the top hat!
How did I... Let's try the warp star.
Oh god!
No!
Such a slow day at work having fun lurking here.
Thank you!
Jerry!
Thank you so much for the 20 gift.
Thank you so much.
I think I missed some more.
Welcome back everybody who came back to membership.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, thank you.
We are gonna wait.
Airbag.
Airbags save lives.
That was so anticlimactic.
He is very impressed.
He is so impressed.
This is the end for you.
We got two options here Henry.
Thank you for the 10 gift.
Alright, surrender!
We are going back home.
Oh, we are going back to solitary.
Maximum security.
What an honor.
Alright, so it was the airship, right?
What did I... Oh that's right, because I...
Slingshot and then it was that whole long thing, right?
That's a magnet.
Pretty!
Thank you so much for the 50 gift.
Thank you!
Holy moly.
Yeah, I pushed the button.
Oopsie.
I can't BS my way out of this one.
Alright, sick ride!
No!
SCAR!
The Betrayed.
Is this a...
What?
How do we live?
Oh Jack, thank you so much for the 20 gift.
Thank you!
I've never heard the full version of this song.
Because this is the same music that they do in...
In Among Us, but I never knew that there was a...
Yeah, the ejected music.
I never knew that there was a real full version.
Wow.
Long live the king.
We got 5 out of 5 endings.
I like that last one.
It was kind of epic to end on.
There's still so many fails we haven't done.
Are there any that you would suggest that I should see?
Anything that's fun.
The sniper fail.
All of them.
That was so many!
It's so many!
Sniper and crossbow.
Oh that's right!
This one, right?
Sniper, crossbow.
Sound war?
OK, we are going to get MLG pro...OK
Noob slayer!
Pallory, thank you so much for the 20 units!
Oh yeah, baby!
Oh yeah!
OK, that one was fun.
I saw it.
There's nothing here.
I want a friend.
Henry Sell.
There's just one more here.
What was it?
Sonic Pulse, right?
I hurt my ear.
I hurt my ears.
Let's see if there are ones that are...like these ones.
I guess some of them are short, right?
Stop being angry.
They are all short.
Let's just go to the next level.
The next thing.
I think we are good.
I think we got them all.
Chapter 5 is very long.
Is it?
OK.
Then we'll go to chapter 5.
Completing the mission.
What?
What has been the mission?
What's been the mission?
Wait, I have to pick?
Oh my god.
Evidence stolen teamed up with...Oh my god.
Wait.
This is insane!
OK.
I think we'll just choose...We got to choose a ghost inmate, right?
And then...
Maybe the thief.
Ruby stolen from Toppats.
Airship destroyed.
Government annoyed.
Toppat leaders fled.
There are so many possibilities.
But the presumed dead one is so awesome too.
But the betrayed one!
I kind of want to do the betrayed.
I kind of want to do the betrayed one.
It sounds awesome.
Do it?
OK.
Maybe I will do...like 2 or 3 of these.
I don't...I don't know if I'm going to do all of them you guys.
I can do like 2 or 3.
My hair looks like string cheese.
Huh?
I thought I was...
I thought this was...Metal Gear for a second.
Duh.
Phantom pan.
My arm!
Oh my gosh they are grey!
Good luck.
Oh!
OK.
I'm afraid it's been 9 years.
Yeah, kick his ass!
Spirit form.
That...wait!
Japanese all of a sudden?
No.
Stop the time.
What is this?
He got a hitter.
Stop me!
The plot twist.
The Japanese...
Stop it.
Please stop.
Wait,
what's happening?
Huh?
I thought it was part of it.
Oh!
My game is not responding.
Is this part of the bit?
Is stopping...is freezing the game also part of freezing the...
He was too strong.
He froze...wait!
He froze everything!
Wait, I'm feeling something in the force.
You guys!
Even I've stopped.
I'm frozen!
So strong he froze the game.
Game is not Japanese good.
Stream is next.
Just kidding.
Hold on.
I'm trying to close the game.
Trying to close the game.
Close window.
Close the program.
Henry Stickmin.exe is not responding.
Oh wait!
No!
Actually this...kind of actually...is very annoying for me.
This is actually kind of annoying for me.
Because of the way...the game is old.
When I had to like...
Give me a second.
I'm going to do something.
Wait, hold on.
Actually if I do this it might cause it.
Oh!
I fixed it.
OK.
OK!
We're good.
We're OK.
Everything is fine.
OK, so maybe I shouldn't do that.
Maybe I...
We'll do the Charlie, right?
Assisted by Charles.
We'll do the Charlie...
Charlie instead.
JoJo was too strong.
I like Charlie, so...
OK.
Charlie.
Smoking man.
OK!
He's like such a silent protagonist.
Potatoes.
No!
Oh!
Wait!
No!
We'll take it down.
Yeah, we'll deal with it.
I'm going to stomp on it.
Yeah!
Oh!
That's me.
Saved you Charles!
A hundred and...there is a hundred and sixty-four unique.
Holy moly!
What about a cupcake?
Worth.
We'll do a drawing.
This one is Shirley.
We'll draw another helicopter.
Or a cloud.
Only clouds.
Nice!
Immediately.
OK!
Invisible bridge?
Go ahead and just make your way across then.
He didn't put it there.
Silly!
Trapeze!
I'm going to have to get more tea in a bit if you guys don't mind.
I
missed one!
Where?
Oh here.
I got him.
I'm going to do a TV broadcast.
Oh!
OK like that.
No way!
It's Seinfeld!
It's a good show Brett!
What about a remote top hat?
Oh wait!
This is Hunter x Hunter, no?
Oh yeah!
I got him.
He's doing his own distraction dance.
He's so good.
Nice!
Buddy!
I'm going to just turn it off.
Turn it off
boys!
That's what that stood for.
Charles!
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry Charlie.
Just for fun.
Let's do the wrench.
I fixed it!
Fix it Freddy!
It was only a level 2 engine.
CF2 joke.
There is too many!
So many...so many...so many...of those...
I never got so much into all the Valve...I say Valve games, but you know what I mean.
I always...I would call them Steam games, because back then they were like the games of Steam, you know what I mean.
So I would always be like, they are the Steam games.
No, they are Valve games.
Oh, then I was right.
The Steam games.
Red Herring.
Steam Developer.
I did get into Portal though.
Thank you for the Donation!
Thank you!
There are so many guys here.
We're gonna...bug juice.
This will turn the user into a bug.
Oh my gosh!
The guys up!
Remember when Steam only had Valve games?
Right!
They were the Valve, yeah.
You're so right.
I forgot that that was...I forgot that that was the case actually.
I guess it only lasts for an hour and bug years.
I don't want to become a Tarakon.
Painting Portal.
No!
I don't want to play Mario 64!
Please!
Gotta collect more of those extra life mushrooms.
Alright, so we're swapping.
We're doing the swapper.
Oh!
Just point the rod at the person you like to swap places with.
It's that easy!
I use this everyday!
It's great!
Thanks Gadget Gabe.
I trust you with my afterlife.
And my life.
I did get this guy.
I remember his hair.
Yeah!
I was going to say I was your leader.
Flanks?
IR Sniper...Sleep Dart!
There you go.
I should totally play Mario 64.
No thank you!
I went through my hell.
Oh no!
The glass!
This one...Oh nice!
Henry is...Henry is...
I was going to say he is like an anti-hero.
I
got that going for me I guess.
Charles?
What's Charlie's last name?
Wow!
There are so many guys.
12 pages worth of men!
Oh my God!
Wow!
But this one.
This is Hunter.
Hunter right?
Gone Hunter.
Anyway, we'll do the horn.
OK
Nice!
That was it?
I feel like there was no other routes here right?
Yeah!
Is this the good ending?
Good ending!
Each route has one ending.
Ah I see!
They don't branch out like normal.
Special Brovert Ops!
Oh yeah baby!
Oh the bro ending!
Oh yeah!
Oh yeah you're right.
I didn't get all of these.
That's OK though.
You know what?
That's OK.
Wait.
0 out of 2?
That's the one that we crashed on.
Alright.
Well then...
I...Oh my gosh!
I don't remember at all what ending I got before.
What would be...
I don't know.
I don't want to try the other one.
I'm scared of trying the other one again.
Wandering Taco!
Thank you so much for the 50!
Thank you!
R-B-H-I-R-O.
R-B-H...
This one?
Right hand man defeated.
Tank stolen.
Pardon.
Oh this is the pardon one.
OK.
This is the...OK.
We'll try it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah and then he saved us.
OK.
Frog!
Please...Pilk!
She's scared.
Wait, wait, wait...
Wait a second!
Ah!
Are we gonna be...Ah!
Are we gonna do the jump?
The Halo jump?
No way!
I like how it's a mix between 3 and 5.
It's like 5 credits.
Failed specialist.
See it Warbur?
Motivator missing!
Directed by...
Ah!
Pilksen!
I can't...I can't say that name.
Frog!
Oh my God.
Eel.
Yummy.
Amelia Esteban.
No!
We have the whole team!
Mr. Dr. Donny, welcome to the membership.
Thank you!
Frog!
Yeah!
Wait, wait, wait...
And they're using MGS1 codec style.
They're crossing the streams.
Metal Gear.
The Right Hand Man.
It's actually such a good name.
It's actually such a good Metal Gear name.
Why do we get to work with...Frog?
OK
Oh CQC!
This won't work though, will it?
Ah!
Convert?
Wait...Wololo!
Looks like they left in a hurry.
I can't believe it was a really Wololo!
Oh my gosh!
OK you guys, give me one second.
I'm gonna go grab a drink real quick.
I'm gonna go grab some more tea real quick and maybe some dinner too.
I'm starting to get hungry.
I only had like half of my dinner earlier so...
OK, I'll be right back.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Sorry about that.
I was out of hot water and didn't realize.
No tea for me, but I got...I got some Gamer Chaps.
Use code Boomer for 10% off your order.
I got some Gamer Chaps.
I got my raspberry drink.
And I got some chicken, like fast food chicken earlier.
That's my dinner.
Yeah, code Boomer.
Alrighty, let's continue onwards.
Suppressing fire.
No, we're gonna dogpile him.
Oh!
Oh yeah dogpile!
Oh dang
Chicken and Gamer Chaps with a Gamer
Dance off!
Oh!
He didn't even let me try.
Suppressing fire.
Stop talking like that.
No!
Why are you so obsessed with me?
Go on, on your feet.
I'll give you one shot.
One shot eh?
We got this.
Rip frog!
No!
Henry bit the dust.
Dance off again.
Hold on, I want to do Rock, Paper, Scissors first.
These are cheating.
These are cheating times.
Laser always wins.
No!
Guys, they are saying no more dance off.
No more fun.
Cheap fighting combo.
Get stun locked?
That pissed me off.
I wasn't even a part of...I was the one doing that as the hero and that pissed me off.
Stop it!
Ocarina?
Wait, what if we rewire him?
He will be our pet.
We will rewire him to like us.
Yeah!
What are you doing?
You are our boss.
You are really going to side with the guy who locked up the chief?
Oh no!
Sorry, I'm trying to eat.
That was such a long cutscene.
Ocarina?
Hello?
No!
You guys, I think my game crashed again.
No, it crashed!
Why
again?
Stopped time.
It stopped time.
Hi-Rez full screen seems to do that.
I'm not in full screen.
I'm in windowed.
We got one ending at least.
But I'm kind of like... I'm salty.
Should be able to go back to where you were.
Well, you think?
Maybe I just won't do the Ocarina then.
It was this one and this one, right?
Open the map!
Oops.
Oh no!
I'm going to have to watch the Metal Gear reference again?
Oh silly me!
Oh what?
OK, I'll skip it.
I'm just kidding.
But what if I danced off here?
Do not!
And what if we stealth here?
What the?
That's so messed up.
This would never have happened at 100.
Wait, what is that a reference to?
Is that Skyrim again?
Wait, what's that interface?
Is it Skyrim?
I don't know.
Oh my gosh, I'm such a gamer.
Wow, I guess we got a world level game.
Wait, wait, wait.
Narwini
Erectus?
He's still speaking in AoE?
OK, I'll use the map here now.
Don't worry.
OK, map.
It was here.
OK, we're just going to finish him.
See ya!
Oh, I have to do the Ocarina.
Oh gosh.
OK, hopefully it doesn't crash.
It worked!
Yay!
No, it didn't.
Something's happening.
Charles!
Unlucky.
I guess we can't get this ending.
That's so disappointing.
Alt-Tab and return.
I think it won't work though, because like...
No, it didn't work.
I was going to say, it's already done the cutscene though.
Why?
I never had these issues with the game before.
Never seen Crash so much.
Me neither!
Never!
I am playing it windowed.
Shut up.
I literally said that.
Use your ears.
Someone said it happens if you play in fullscreen and I said I'm not playing in fullscreen.
I'm playing windowed.
Let me try again.
I mean, have you tried playing windowed?
I just got here.
OK.
How is this so stinky, right?
Lower your graphics.
This is so stinky.
Maybe we do like a different one.
This one is kind of fun, right?
The fake to death.
One is kind of cool.
I like the betrayed one too.
I think I clicked menu instead of map.
There we go.
My bad.
The betrayed one I wanted to do also.
This is the betrayed, right?
Yeah.
I barely even got anywhere into this one.
What?
Playing in windowed was originally supposed to be Resident Evil 4.
No way!
OK.
Spirit form?
Which is the correct answer you guys?
Which is the correct one?
Because spirit is what crashed the game earlier.
Spirit form won't take you to an ending.
OK.
Blade is the...
Blade?
Let's try blade form.
If I'm getting five guys, I'm gonna be...
Oh my God, it's so epic.
Oh my God!
No, our sword.
But we got him in the eye.
I'm gonna eat that.
I'm gonna eat that right up.
Oh my God.
Lure?
Oh.
That's gotta be the play of the game.
Wait.
No!
Is this Overwatch?
We're just standing there.
Dead game.
Just kidding.
Baseball bat.
This is Marvel Rivals moment.
Home run!
We're too good!
OK, Y type move.
Big blast!
Blast.
Oh, it's a Z move.
I get it, like a Z move.
That's so stupid.
Instead of a Z type... Z move, it's a Y... OK, I get it.
I was like, what is...
Oh my God!
What are you going to do?
Staple?
Drop airship.
Airship!
Oh my God, the top bats.
Oh, stop.
It's so horrible.
Oh God.
Let's drop him instead.
Yeah!
Feel my pain!
Anyone available?
There is an attacker in the cockpit.
Oh, OK.
They...
They predicted that.
They would know, right?
They perfected that move, so...
OK, let's staple him.
A new skin healer.
Like a good captain would.
Oh, he's still alive.
Mission complete.
Revenge!
Alright, we'll try and go back to this one.
Let's see if the Ocarina works this time.
Let's hope, let's hope, let's hope!
You break my game!
I don't know what's going on here.
I'm listening to the...I'm listening to the cutscene.
We are listening.
Is this the actual ending?
I'm imagining.
Yeah, it's radio.
You guys use your imagination!
This is just like radio.
Was that the ending?
Audiobook.
I think we did it.
Close the program.
Open the game.
Well wait, I got three endings, right?
Well, kind of.
Technically.
Technically, right?
Liquidated Dingleton III.
Welcome to my mission.
Thank you!
If you're running Discord in the background, it apparently crashes.
What?
No way!
Wait, I do have Discord open.
I'll exit out.
Click Discord.
Seriously?
Should we try one more time?
One last time.
Oh, dang it.
I did not mean to press that.
Map.
It doesn't say that we got the ending.
It doesn't say.
Alright.
Ok, I exit out of Discord.
That's it!
We actually got it!
It actually worked!
Wait, who sent that?
Who sent that in earlier?
Where are you?
Who sent that?
Tisonic!
Thank you!
You deserve your credit.
Thank you so much!
Look at him so smug.
Yay!
Master Bounty Hunter!
Thank you!
We did it!
And we got the Metal Gear.
We got the Metal Gear stuff!
That was so good!
Yay!
We can see the JoJo fail.
It's so long.
Wait, why is it...Oh, it's because it's what we are on.
Just kidding.
I was like, why is it outlined?
We could finish the JoJo one.
In fact, while we do that, I will eat.
We'll do the JoJo.
Here we go.
I'll keep eating while you eat JoJo.
I forgot about the cursed Nihongo.
What?
That's crazy.
They stand now.
Hontou ni fist ga stop me.
This Japanese is killing me.
Oh my God!
You're just a man!
OK, this is where...
It actually worked!
What?
Oh no, they even got the song!
Oh my God.
It doesn't seem right, but I don't know enough about anime to dispute it.
Oh, it was right at the very end.
That's so frustrating.
We had to go through the whole cutscene and then it froze.
Anyways guys, I think that's where I'm going to stop it today.
I think that's where I'll stop it today.
I had a lot of fun!
Are you going to do a part 2?
Probably not.
We got a whole bunch of stuff.
I know there's a crazy amount of endings and everything, but...
We got 3.
I think it's pretty good.
Sorry about the crashes, but luckily we got a fix in the end.
This is fun though.
We got the Wololo.
That was so funny.
I can't believe it.
So fun!
It was so fun.
And yeah, what a game.
What a product of it's time.
But also seeing some of the new additions like FNAF.
That was so crazy.
There was something else too.
There was like the...
The boy.
All these references make me feel old.
I'm going to be thinking about 2000's era Newgrounds and NND memes all night.
Yeah, but where were the Meat and Fuck memes?
That's peak Newgrounds.
Where were they?
The FNAF reference was crazy for it's time.
He predicted the future.
Hmm...
The what?
You guys don't...you guys know?
You guys know?
That was the only thing I played on Newgrounds.
Um...
Thank you guys for 100 Stickmin.
Not Stickman.
Stickmin.
Otamito!
Thank you guys!
Have a good day, have a good night and I'll see you guys...
Thanks for the 10 gift in my face!
I'll see you guys later!
Bye bye!
Thank you!